[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants quel voyage j'espère
que vous avez passé de belles vacances
et que vous avez été très sage comme
nounours oui bravo
nous sommes bien contents dit peu trop
or aussi j'étais très sache mamou - elma
feu de bon dans tous nos métiers a
grossi mon cher gros ours
appelez moi plutôt nounours patron je
préfère d'accord mon gros nounours oh
pardon d'accord nounours qui croient que
celle un peu tendre et patron je veux
relire la lettre de petit oui une mûre
apple houle que de l'être ils nous ont
beaucoup écrit tous nos petits ennuis
de vrais mongeau qui je lis
pierre marchand de sable
leur petit ours les ch'tis
nous avons passé deux grandes vacances
aux portes de la mer
vous savez on a beaucoup grandi et nous
allons maintenant tous les deux à
l'école on connaît deux petits l'enfant
tout petits qui ne sont pas allés en
vacances peut il s'appelle nicolas et
pimprenelle pimprenelle et nicolas 16
ans de famille prénom et semoy s'unir
patron nicolas eux offrent du il habite
rue des enfants au sol
au dernier étage de la plus grande
maison vous nous ferez un grand plaisir
si vous allez les voir chaque soir et
nous comptons sur toi cher petit new
york pour les aider à aller se coucher
le petit
maman dis que ce sont les enfants les
plus sages qu'elle connaît nous on est
grand et on va se coucher tout seul on
vous regardera à la télévision gros
bisous mirabel et p'tit louis que ce
gentil qu'aux jo oui c'est très gentil
de leur part
alan nounours il faut aller voir ses
deux petits enfants
renseigne toi s'il habite bien ici porto
mode boussole l'étoile
pouvez vous me dire si c'est bien ici
qu'habitent nicolas et pimprenelle frise
y est monsieur nounours il habite juste
en dessous de votre nuage là où la
lumière brise
merci gracieuse mademoiselle nettoie je
peux y aller patron vasina nord ce jeu
shot molsheim
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc bon
avant ce que c'est pas me prenais je
fais ce qu est qu il a on sort les ans
au supplice bonsoir nicolas bonsoir âpre
mais tu connais nom de nom et qui vient
jouer avec nous monsieur nono tu
viendras aussi demain oui à condition
vous allez vite vous coucher on y va on
et vanilla
[Musique]
faire pogner le nouveau petit ovni chute
intervenue au nonce à demain bonne unico
la bonne nuit pas pr neil bonne nuit
tous nos petits amis allez vous coucher
bien sagement embrasser vite vos parents
et nous reviendrons vous voir sans faute
demain soir
bonne nuit à demain
[Musique]
oh